[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing lavender
Brown if you can't remember who lavender
is she's in the Harry Potter series from
the very beginning she's mentioned as
soon as the very first book and her face
is first shown in the film adaptation
the Chamber of Secrets lavender was a
pureblood witch that started the
hogwarts in the same year as Harry
Potter lavender was sorted in the
Gryffindor House and was actually the
first in Gryffindor a year as expressed
in the following excerpt but brown
lavender became the first new Gryffindor
the table on the far left exploded with
Cheers
lavender actually shared a dormitory
with Hermione among other girls while
spending time at Hogwarts lavender was
quite studious and took a particular
interest in divination on top of that
she had a massive crush on Ron Weasley
loyally supported professor Trelawney
and joined Dumbledore's Army she was
even brutally attacked by Fenrir
Greyback with that brief introduction of
lavender out of the way let's explore
why she was played by three yes three
different actresses throughout the films
in the Chamber of Secrets we see the
very first actress to play lavender
Brown Cathleen Cooley the truth is this
early on in the films lavender is not a
particularly important character she
doesn't really have any dialogue and
she's really just there as a background
character though she was mentioned in
the books in the films
lavender was never referred to directly
by any of the other characters at least
what Cathleen assumed the role after the
Chamber of Secrets was released the
Prisoner of Azkaban followed the
Prisoner of Azkaban immediately followed
the Chamber of Secrets but interestingly
enough lavender Brown was still recast
Cathleen Cooley was promptly replaced
with actress Jennifer Smith the role of
lavender at this stage was still a
non-speaking one but she did occur quite
frequently as a background character in
the film I'm not sure why Cooley was
replaced this was around the same time
that Kuran took over the films but I'd
imagine that it was just that cool he
was unavailable for the role it's also
worth mentioning that Jennifer Smith has
been commonly confused with actress
Candice Morris who plays Keller in the
Prisoner of Azkaban similar to
after one film Smith did not appear in
any of the films again at this point we
would see a hiatus for lavenders
character altogether until 2009 when the
half-blood prince was released at this
point
lavender became a shocker speaking
character and was played by none other
than actress Jessie cave cave had made
her acting debut in the drama summer
hill and beat out 7,000 other girls and
the audition for the role of lavender in
the film so you might be asking yourself
why another recast why cave the reason
for this is that by the time the sixth
film came out it was time for lavenders
character to really blossom she went
from background character to
front-and-center and Warner Brothers
decided that they wanted a more
established actress in the role because
the previous portrayals of lavender was
so trivial in comparison it's likely
that they never properly assessed the
acting abilities of Coolio Smith
they likely just needed someone to fill
lavender space
I expected the casting director just to
sign the name lavender Brown to the two
previous actresses to keep track of the
minor roles as the films progressed
Warner Brothers were scrutinized for the
casting of cave primarily because they
replaced the two black actresses with
ultimately a white actress I personally
don't think the casting of cave was a
racially driven decision at all as she
was an experienced actress hired for a
portrayal of lavender that required or
experienced cave was excellent in the
role but I'm not a huge fan of like a
continuity and Warner Brothers part they
have a bit of a history with a lack of
continuity throughout the films but I
suppose that can be forgiven on the
basis that the films were shot over a
10-year span so I hope that answers the
question why was lavender brown played
by three different actresses maybe you
never noticed or even realized that
lavender was a character before the half
footprints if you didn't read the books
that is well now you know and that's it
for this video if you guys have any
questions on this let me know down below
please like the video if you enjoyed it
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]